messieurs dames prennent au jeu le plus
peur c'est l'ultime game bas mais sûr
s'il bouge beaucoup quand je parle de
temps aux excuses et que tu ajoutes eux
se trouvent sur le cheveu dans le mur un
jeu qui a l'air complètement perchet qui
du coup m'attire énormément parce qu'il
est très atypique on adore tous cas
typique avec toi mec qui se passe les
têtes ont régulièrement on vient
d'emménager dans une nouvelle maison et
il y a dans la cave un cheveu qui sort
du mur ouais ouais aujourd'hui en test
un jeu comme ça vous allez c'est parti
premier jour c'est quoi ces journées
stress mon corps ça c'est cancérigène ça
mais c'est horrible c'est une basse aux
comptines [ __ ] bon vous venez
d'emménager nouvelle maison nouveau
travail nouvelle vie ce que vous avez à
dire pendant que tu monter des étagères
tu as remarqué quelque chose au sous sol
un cheveu dans le mr bah voilà le beau
poil qui dépasse du mur à la basse et
arrêter ça fait beaucoup de bien si ça
va mal dans ta vie tu écoutes cette
basse 30 secondes tu l'avais tulard est
et tout va mieux alors il faut faire
quoi du coup sûr est que je veux faut
cliquer faut le tirer
je voulais le plus in situ la retirer
maintenant on va dormir
ok jour 2 ok le jeu le plus perché de
tous les temps tes voisins arrivent pour
t'accueillir va chercher du vin
peut-être y at-il une bouteille dans le
sous sol
à dos mais ce que je veux et fait le
tour de la bouteille et ben voilà et ben
voilà on pour la bouteille et on prend
le cheveu il est de nouveau là tu sais
que tu en as envie
allez vas-y retire le bonbon prônée par
les sentiments et les dialyses et alizée
aller dans mes honnorat vous a plu je
crois jusqu'à toi un noeud wac opération
jour 3 ok c'est à quoi est ce qu'on est
en train de vivre c'est une aventure
extraordinaire
la dernière nuit été rugueuse tu n'as
pas pu dormir sa cause du cheveu dans le
mur c'est ça ce cheveu et tenter
pourquoi ce cheveu était encore là tu
est pourtant sûr de l'avoir retiré la
veille actuellement tu n'as pas le temps
de penser à ça tu dois aller travailler
il se fait tard fin juillet a quand même
un choix qui leur apparaît dans l'ue
mais enfin c'est inquiétant tu prends à
rtt et puis tu résout ce problème tu
brûles ta maison au travail ou notre
obama pour faire des recherches
quand font faire des recherches qui sait
qu'on appelle quelqu'un de neuf dans
cette recherche
alors alors comment faire on allume le
pc voix à m ce que j'aime faire la boule
à zéro ça continue vous l'avez vu n'est
ce pas elles savent eux dans c'est quoi
cette ambiance bizarre la [ __ ] cliquez
pour continuer jour 4
on se fait hanté par un cheveu quoi est
ce qu est un truc plus nulle pour
d'augmenter de plusieurs de la fête de
bienvenue tu n'es pas retourner au sous
sol ben pourquoi tu as peur d'un cheveu
elle n'a pas de courage le com
et s'il était encore la cia inside qui
te met la pression pour vraiment un truc
de fou et ya le cheveu dans le mur dans
ce cas mettons fins et d'histoire une
fois pour toutes à arracher le ok ok je
suis prêt je suis prêt je suis prêt au
au couteau mais si tu le tir ou steve o
que c'est pareil et là mesdames nous
dirons que nous le poil quand tu
l'arraché mais plus notoires repousser
quand tu le couple et repousse vite et
dur je te retrouve avec des gens de yéti
et bien mesdames
cet homme ne vous écoute pas puisqu'il
prend ce couteau mr je peux le temps de
lire mais rj fait une fausse manip on va
y aller au couteau oh ça ne marche pas
le mur ne se casse pas tu as besoin d'un
outil plus puissants et de péter mur
carrément dan
s'il ya quelqu'un qui est mort dans le
mur c'est la fin de ma chaîne youtube
jour 5 arrêter avec cette basse ça
m'énerve vous êtes un monsieur bricolage
vous ne vous souvenez pas de si vous
avez dormi manger ou si vous êtes allée
au travail ou si vous avez arraché un de
vos cheveux pour le mettre dans le mur
en fait c'est nous que seydou [ __ ] et
vous avez de moins en moins de cheveux
sur la tête
voila voila c'est tout si seulement tout
ce que tu sais c'est que tu veux te
débarrasser de ce cheveu dans le mur oui
oui bah oui sinon sinon on s'en bat les
couilles
on laisse à sa place on s'en fout c'est
un chef de famille alors là mais qu'on
va se prendre à la perceuse moche loto
elle nous en [ __ ] waya waya waya de
marteau piqueur bosch aussi en principe
hyper cher c'était très cher mais ça va
résoudre tout problème
attendez je vais me suicider avec ce
truc
oh [ __ ] il ya l'air d'avoir une
chambre derrière le mur al khadamat cas
là tu as besoin de lumière pour mieux
voir ta lampe torche sur est en haut des
marches on voit la preuve est qu'on va
revenir le mur sera re la nord la vérité
est proche il ya plus de cheveux mais le
mur s'est reconstruit est ce qu'un maçon
de notre famille parce qu'on est
portugais est passé par là this is the
question
il y avait un trou ici il n'est plus là
merci pour cette information jour 6 il
aurait pas de saint jean mais battue a
fait la meilleure nuit de toute ta life
le cheveu a disparu le trou n'a jamais
été leur tué en sécurité maintenant
enfin way et d'ouïe c'est quoi c'est
quoi walt that was there it mine faut
cliquer ça s'approche je vois un cheveu
au loin je vois un cheveu moins loin je
vois un cheveu presque proches gravé
dans la roche sont de famille et de
proches ses snipers des cas il est de
retour et ce qu'on doit cliquer nani ça
pisse le sang atteint screamer en bois
enfin je veux dire la meuf était
vraiment en bois c'est la mode de
pinocchio qui nous a fait une blague qui
n'a jamais ménagé
non c'est ton ancienne maison non
tranché un travail dans ton ancienne vie
et ça c'était ta femme décédée
c'est la fin est ce que c'est vraiment
la fin c'est la fin c'était ça le twist
de faim et ce jeu a été fait par un
enfant de 6 ans en fait c'est au cours
de techno que tu fais ça à je te faire
le truc avec la led là maintenant tu
connais un jeu d'horreur un peu moisie
ouais je n'aime pas cette vidéo sur le
chef d'un jour n'était pas là mais ça
vous a plu [ __ ] mais j'étais hyper
attiré par le principe du jeu par
l'image partout il a chuté un peu pété
quoi on peut imaginer une chute à
l'exception de quoi mais pas trop à deux
gros chêne vert savoyarde et merci
d'avoir joué à ce jeu complètement
perché avec moi n'avaient plus perché de
la chaîne c'est sûr à trier portez vous
bien le château en pis